are you a morning person or a night owl
morning coffee person or tea guy coffee
in the morning tea in the afternoon
what's the first thing you do when you
wake up everyone where am i running
shoes what's on your work desk right now
too many computers to count what's on
your smartphone homescreen
ah the number one icon wonder list Comic
Sans good or bad fault good fun
favorite workday time waster Cortana
jokes favorite personal possession Oh
cricket bat signed by Sachin Tendulkar
would you rather go to a Clippers game
with Steve Ballmer or play bridge with
Bill Gates I think I'll play I'll go to
a Clippers game with Steve Ballmer how
do you run listen more talk less and be
decisive when the time comes the one
trait that I look for in new hires is do
they create clarity do they create
energy if you could explain cricket
rules to some what in the u.s. what's
the one thing you would tell it's
impossible who's been the greatest
influence
my parents my dad is a economist leftist
Marxist my mom was a Sanskrit drama
professor they could hardly agree on
anything
so therefore it gave me the room to form
my own opinions but they had great
values and that helped what's the best
professional advice you've ever think
you believe in yourself more so than you
think you do I am Satya Nadella CEO of
Microsoft all right